-My next guest is already
a Critics' Choice Award winner
who stars in a film
that's nominated for six Oscars,
and he's only 8 years old.
From "Minari," which is
currently available in theaters,
on A24 Screening Room,
and on demand,
pease welcome Alan Kim!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, buddy!
Oh! [ Laughs ]
Wow. How you doing, buddy?
Welcome to the show.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
I'm so glad to be here.
[ Audience awws ]
-Are you kidding me?
Stop it. This is...
[ Laughter ]
Now, buddy, you're
8 years old -- am I correct?
-Yes.
It's April 9th right now.
So, in around 14 days,
I'm turning 9.
-Oh! Well, happy early birthday!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-What do you want
for your birthday?
Do you know?
-What I want for my birthday...
That's a hard one.
-It is?
-Um, well, definitely not
another hoverboard.
-You -- You don't --
You already have a hoverboard?
-Yes.
-Oh.
-I do.
-I love hoverboards.
-Well, then...
yeah, I guess a new bike.
-A new bike? Yeah?
You need a new one?
-Yeah.
My old one...
[ Clicks tongue ]
[ Laughter ]
...the chain keeps falling off.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, get a new one there.
Are you going to --
Are you going to celebrate,
have a cake and all that stuff?
-Well, we were thinking
to going to Boomers!
but [breathes sharply]
it closes on weekdays, so...
[ Audience awws ]
-Are you kidding me
with this kid?
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
What is Boomers!?
And we could probably make sure
they open for you.
What's Boomers!?
What is Boomers!?
-Well, Boomers! -- it's a --
kind of like Chuck E. Cheese
or Dave & Buster's.
-Yeah!
-Except it has, like, rides.
-Oh, wow.
-And like a miniature version
of only the rides at Disneyland.
-Wow! That's --
Are you scared to go on rides,
or you're cool with those?
-No.
I'm cool with those.
I just, like, don't like --
like, I went to Boomers!
like, on Wednesday,
and I [breathes sharply] --
I went to one ride,
and that had a water fountain.
And I went through that,
and I got drenched.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. You got wet.
I -- You know, I --
I have a ride --
if you ever go
to Orlando, Florida,
I actually have a roller coaster
at the Universal theme park.
-Oh, wow!
-Yeah. Yeah.
You got to go on that.
You will not get wet.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, I want to talk about
your movie, if you don't mind --
"Minari."
Congratulations on this.
Winning the award
is unbelievable,
and you -- great performance.
Can you tell us, everyone,
what the movie is about --
"Minari"?
-Well, "Minari" is
about a Korean-American family
that moves to Arkansas
to get a better living
than they did in California.
And the grandma comes
to babysit the children
while the parents
are away at work.
-Yeah.
-But David, my character,
doesn't like the grandma
at first.
But throughout the movie,
she starts growing on him.
-Yeah.
She's really funny,
and you're really funny
in the movie, too.
Did you enjoy making it?
Did you have fun making it?
-Yeah.
Especially the pee scene.
That was really funny.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, no spoilers, but, yeah,
so, that was a good --
that was a good scene, as well.
I want to say congratulations
on everything.
And, man, oh, man,
you couldn't be more charming.
Happy early birthday.
Have fun at Boomers!
Tell 'em all I said, "Hi,"
please.
-[ Chuckles ] Thank you.
-Yeah, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Alan Kim in "Minari."
Take a look.
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Pretty boy, pretty boy!
Pretty --
-I'm not pretty!
I'm good-looking!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I'm talking
about right there, buddy!
-Yep!
-Alan Kim!
Please come back, buddy,
whenever you can.
You're more than welcome back.